en el oeste de Francia los 88 años ha
muerto Paco rabanne justamente fue allí
cuando siendo apenas un niño llegó junto
a su madre y sus hermanos huyendo del
franquismo que había dado muerte a su
padre en el país Vasco fue su madre
justamente la que lo introdujo en el
mundo de la moda ella trabajaba como
costurera para el diseñador español
valenciaga sin embargo rabanne estudió
arquitectura y terminó la carrera Aunque
nunca ejerció Y esos conocimientos lo
puso al servicio de la moda fue sobre
todo un vanguardista en el uso de los
materiales el Metal primero lo que le
valió las críticas de muchas personas
entre ellos Gabriel Chanel pero luego
también el plástico la fibra óptica y
hasta el cemento él decía que en una
época después de Las Guerras cuando el
mundo estaba en pleno cambio la moda
seguía siendo muy conservadora en la
emancipación de las mujeres justamente
vistió a muchas francesas él decía que
las tenía que vestir como unas guerreras
en momentos en que estaban luchando por
sus derechos sin embargo lo que le dio
verdadero éxito económico arrabane
fueron perfumes en el año 68 la marca
catalana puig compró Paco rabanne y
diseñó varios perfumes que hasta el día
de hoy se mantienen entre los top cinco
de ventas mundiales eso permitió que
funcionara su marca de alta costura y
también de petapaste pero finalmente él
se retiró para dedicarse a dos pasiones
la música africana y antillana y también
las premoniciones él se creía una suerte
de brujo sin embargo las críticas
vinieron cuando se equivocó tras
predecir la caída de la estación
espacial rusa mir en los años 90 fue
justamente Bretaña que se convirtió en
su Refugio definitivo